les jours se suivent et se ressemblent à
l'onp et 12 à l'île italienne voit
accosté des embarcations de fortune avec
à leur bord des migrants venus
principalement de libye ils sont plus de
2000 à être arrivés dans les dernières
24 heures un flux journalier encore
jamais vues sur l'île qui inquiète les
élus locaux et 6000 migrants débarquant
en jour la machine d'accueil tient à peu
près le coût mais si 3000 à 4000
personnes arrivent
que faisons nous des chiffres qui ne
cessent d'augmenter en 2021 selon le
ministère de l'intérieur près de 13000
personnes ont débarqué sur les côtes
italiennes depuis le début de l'année
contre 4200 en 2020
l'italie a donc été sommé de réagir au
plus vite le premier ministre mario
draghi
déjà confronté à la campagne de
vaccination doit faire face à une
nouvelle problématique
une aubaine pour ses opposants
politiques qui n'ont pas tardé à
s'emparer du sujet avec les millions
d'italiens en difficulté nous ne pouvons
pas nous permettre de nous occuper de
milliers de clandestins
nous lui demandons que l'italie se
comporte comme l'espagne la grèce et la
france qui n'attendent pas l'europe mais
défendre leur territoire par eux mêmes
l'italie doit maintenant compter sur une
aide extérieure les accords de malte de
censé permettre la redistribution
automatique des demandeurs d'asile sont
toujours interrompues à cause de la
crise sanitaire rome compte désormais
sur le prochain conseil européen qui
aura lieu à la fin du mois de mai pour
les réactiver